many of the stars of super bad were
launched to instant fame after the movie
became a giant hit but not all of them
were so lucky whatever happened to
Martha MacIsaac here's what she's been
up to and how she looks today
in 2011 MacIsaac took on the lead role
in hoax for the holidays a little-known
Canadian Christmas movie with an unusual
premise she plays a rebellious teen who
hoodwinked the residents of her small
town when she throws her coffee against
the wall of a donut store and
manipulates the stain so that it
resembles the face of Jesus Christ what
is it Jesus Christ for the Canadian
MacIsaac the film was very much a
homecoming and she had worked with a lot
of the same crew members on the CBC TV
series Emily of New Moon when she was a
kid in an interview with AXS she said
they were all like long-lost family to
get to come back and see all of them as
an adult was incredible in 2012 MacIsaac
went from playing a troublesome teen in
small-town Canada to playing a
troublesome teen in the White House she
was a main cast member in all 13
episodes of the NBC sitcom 1600 Penn as
the ordinarily straight-laced but
accidentally pregnant first daughter
Bill Pullman perhaps best known for
playing the president and the sci-fi
classic Independence Day once again took
on the role of commander-in-chief much
to the amusement of his co-stars
in an interview with she said media said
MacIsaac confirmed that Pullman could
handle the teasing saying he's one of
the nicest and down-to-earth men I've
ever had the pleasure of meeting he's
just one of those rare gems MacIsaac
scare achter also bore some coincidental
familiarity as she was named Becca just
like her super bad character sadly for
the actress her first full-time American
TV show didn't last very long it
suffered mediocre reviews and was axed
by NBC after a single season MacIsaac
married producer and director Tori
Catalano in 2010 but sadly their union
ended just five years later in that time
they worked together on a handful of
projects the first of which was a 2013
short named seasick sailor the two split
in 2015 the same year that catalano's
debut feature film almost anything later
renamed Milwaukee was really
it's a saucy dramedy about a bunch of
thirtysomethings testing the limits of
monogamy
it features MacIsaac as greta a woman
struggling with trust issues that
premise seems a little awkward now that
we know her marriage to Catalano was on
the rocks at the time post-divorce
MacIsaac has found a new man in her life
his name is Kyle McCullough and he's
dabbled in acting but he now appears to
be focused on working in the video game
industry in December 2018 the two had a
surprise wedding with none other than
Paul McCartney helping McCullagh out
with the proposal MacIsaac isn't
particularly close to any of the guys
from Superbad but she and Emma Stone
remain near and dear friends having even
spent a few years living together in
2012 MacIsaac presented her powell with
the first ever MTV Trailblazer award a
title that stone has more than lived up
to in the years since she got her first
Oscar nomination for 2014's Birdman and
then one a couple years later for lala
land and just like best friends should
be MacIsaac has been right by stone side
every step of the way and that has
proven herself as one of the most
enduring and captivating actresses of
our generation she's a gifted
entertainer and a very dear friend in
2017 MacIsaac joined fellow actresses
anna o'reilly and sugar lynn beard for a
pre oscars get together with all three
sporting t-shirts and support of stones
bid for Best Actress a couple of months
after the Oscar buzz had died down
Stoney MacIsaac went to a relaxing trip
to Sonoma in Northern California a
picturesque City located in the heart of
a world-renowned winemaking region Mac
Isaac's most recent major film role was
in 2017 sports biopic battle of the
sexes it's based on the true story of
the 1973 exhibition match between Billie
Jean King and Bobby Riggs a historic
moment in the history of women's tennis
King won in three straight sets meaning
Riggs who had belittled women's tennis
in the media had to eat his words
King was played by Emma Stone and her
bestie was right there alongside her
MacIsaac had the honor of plain-jane
peaches parka wits who is a member of
the original nine a group of female
players that included King and changed
tennis forever as it turns out the fact
that MacIsaac and stone are BFFs in real
life actually helped
and the wool co-director Valerie Faris
told cinema blend she and Emma are
friends and it just felt like if we
build this group of women that have a
certain camaraderie that can't hurt in
addition to battle of the sexes MacIsaac
has appeared in a couple of small
independent films the past few years
first up was unicorn store the
directorial debut of brie Larson
it features Larson as a woman who
receives a mysterious invitation to
fulfill her dreams the film also stars
samuel l.jackson Joan Cusack and Bradley
Whitford and it had its world premiere
at the 2017 Toronto International Film
Festival next up was the thriller what
keeps you alive which premiered at the
2018 South by Southwest festival it's
about a couple celebrating their first
anniversary at a remote cabin MacIsaac
plays a former childhood friend who
arouses suspicion when she shows up as
for the Future MacIsaac unfortunately
doesn't appear to have any film or TV
projects arriving any time soon but
judging by her Instagram she's been
keeping herself busy by baking delicious
looking cakes check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
and actresses are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]